madame la ministre vous vous demandez
peut-être pourquoi nous avons pensé
alors que ça n'est pas dans votre projet
commencer par une réforme d'ordre
constitutionnel
je me permets de souligner qu'il n'ya
pas d'étape dans la décentralisation qui
n'ait été précédée est ouverte par une
réforme de la constitution ce fut le cas
pour les lois defferre précédé d'une
révision constitutionnelle qui a érigé
notamment la région en collectivités
territoriales ce fut le cas en 2003 lors
de l'étape franchie à l'initiative du
président jacques chirac et de son
premier ministre jean pierre raffarin
pour le renforcement de la
décentralisation ce devrait être le cas
aujourd'hui
si nous sommes porteurs d'une ambition
forte pour les libertés locales et nous
sommes porteurs d'une ambition forte
pour les libertés locales
le plus important pour nous c'est tout
d'abord de protéger la commune pour
qu'elle ne devienne pas une coquille
vide
deuxièmement d'empêcher
d'empêcher que l'état récupère les
pouvoirs qu'ils décentralise car la
pratique française forte de cet atavisme
centralisateur hérité de l'absolutisme
royal du centralisme napoléonien de
l'étatisme de la troisième république
cet atavisme centralisateur n'a cessé
d'agir pour récupérer les pouvoirs qui
était décentralisée comment a t'on
procédé en france très simplement par la
norme et par l'argent les normes se sont
multipliés
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
locales n'a cessé d'être rognés et c'est
toujours le cas aujourd'hui
le troisième point c'est de garantir
l'indépendance financière des
collectivités elles sont de plus en plus
sous la dépendance de l'état pour
l'attribution de leurs moyens et nous
voulons mettre un coup d'arrêt à cette
pratique qui n'est pas seulement le fait
de votre gouvernement chère madame la
ministre
c'est le fait de votre gouvernement mais
c'est aussi le fait de ceux qui vous ont
précédé le quatrième point c'est de
permettre à chaque catégorie de
collectivité d'avoir des compétences à
géométrie variable autour d'un tronc
commun pour cesser de pratiquer cette
uniformité bien française qui stérilise
les initiatives ils sont jamais bien sûr
opposé france urbaine et france rurale
le cinquième point c'est de faire en
sorte car c'est important aussi que les
préfets de département retrouve le
pouvoir de s'engager auprès des
collectivités
alors que depuis des années les services
de l'état ont été centralisées au niveau
régional les sens les préfets de
département en marge du pouvoir
d'instruire les décisions et de les
prendre
et cette évolution est évidemment
préjudiciable aux collectivités de
proximité
et qu'ils n'ont plus d'interlocuteur
suffisamment capables de s'engager au
niveau local et donc il arrive que
l'exercice des libertés locales soit
entravée par ce centralisme régionales
je dois vous dire qu'à mes yeux le
centralisme régional ne vaut guère mieux
que le centralisme de l'est